on the day US oil prices fell farther
than ever before Iranian media seemed to
relish the news many say the United
States has used oil like a weapon
against Iran for years and its
effectiveness was ending Iran's
president said US sanctions had helped
his country become less susceptible to
the tumbling market Iran he said is now
less reliant on oil hemay eshwara
naphthas joomla muhammad's all oil-rich
countries including us were hit by the
situation some more some less but we
will be here less than other countries
Iran has spent years trying to move away
from an oil-based economy but still
sells oil through backchannels
if we want to say that Iran's economy
was not affected by the oil price drop I
think that's wrong it has definitely
been impacted but if other countries
fell from the 10th floor then Iran fell
from the second floor because Iran has
already fallen in the past due to
sanctions Iran is trying to make up for
lost I already knew by manufacturing
more goods it can sell abroad as well as
building up other industries such as
plastics mining and agriculture
the government says non-oil exports to
China and neighboring countries have
increased but oil and gas are still
vital to its economy Iran has expanded
refining capacity in recent years and
unveiled a new oil field in the
southwest of the country it also has a
large domestic market because of US
sanctions Iran has been unable to freely
sell its oil the government has for
years been trying to diversify the
economy to get away from depending on
oil as its main source of revenue but
one of the things that leaders said they
had to do was remove state subsidies on
things like gas to ease the government's
financial burden
in November last year the price of
petrol at the pumps doubled in some
cases tripled overnight it sparked the
worst protest since the 1979 Islamic
Revolution the death toll from the
violent security crackdown that followed
is still unclear when global oil prices
fell earlier this month some on social
media began asking for the savings to be
passed on to them now that the oil price
is equal to the price of dirt shouldn't
the price of gasoline and other crude
products go down too said one gasoline
in the US and Europe is cheaper than
Iran joked another a common saying here
is that prices go up never down and
there's another financial pinch coming
the latest government budget includes a
plan to increase revenues by raising
taxes Zayn Basra via al Jazeera Tehran